And we're alive.
How are you sir?
How are you?
Good to see you again.
I'm thrilled to be here.
Thanks for doing this,
man.
Thanks for having,
I know I should tell people before we get started,
I did not know when I asked you to come back on that you were heavily involved
in this whole vaccine debate.
What I wanted to have you on to talk about is tropical diseases because a,
I remember when we did that Scifi show,
um,
you explained to me that some ungodly percentage of people that live in tropical
climates are infected by parasites.
That's right.
Well,
my day job is developing vaccines for tropical diseases.
We developed the vaccines no one else will make because they're for the world's
poorest people,
so that we call them tropical diseases,
but there really are diseases of poverty.
The vaccine issue,
the,
the advocacy issue around vaccines and autism is kind of a new thing that I got
drawn into just because I'm a parent of an adult daughter with autism and I make
vaccines.
So it was a natural that I'd get drawn into it.
Yeah.
So when I said that you were going to come on,
then I got inundated by people that are,
you know,
the,
the vaccine thing is such a polarizing issue.
Yeah.
It's awful.
And so many people seem to think they absolutely know what causes what,
especially when it comes to something like autism,
which is a,
it's a huge issue in this country.
It's a huge issue around the world and it doesn't,
didn't use to seem to be,
the question is,
was that because it was undiagnosed?
Was that because it just,
there's,
it's more prevalent today.
What do you think,
what is your take on that?
I don't think we really know.
Um,
one thing's for sure we're diagnosing people with autism who we diagnosed as
something else in the past,
you know,
whether it was,
really horrible diagnosis,
we'd use pejorative terms like mental retardation.
It's a matter of Jamie
just telling the clock was off.
Oh,
okay.
Sorry.
Should we start again?
No,
no,
no.
It's okay.
He was just saying,
he was just telling me that there are clock is screwed up because of the
daylight savings time.
Sorry.
Totally unrelated to what you're selling.
Countries clack is screwed up because of daylight savings.
Yeah.
Right.
Um,
so,
so we don't know.
We don't,
well,
you know,
one thing is clear that the number of diagnoses is going up,
but part of that is because what we used to call pejorative,
things like mental retardation now get thrown into the autism category.
The other thing not to do it absolutely.
You know,
so,
well,
you know,
now we call it as part of the autism spectrum.
Um,
we also,
because autism often has a lot of associated intellectual disabilities.
Not always,
but sometimes the other is that,
um,
can I pause,
is that based on a APP aptitude tests?
Like how do,
how do they decide,
how do they decide what's autism?
They have a list of diagnostic categories,
but it's not crazy.
It's not like you can someone if they test positive for a disease.
That's right.
Well,
although it,
you know,
one of the interesting side pieces to this is,
the,
there's a group of people out there who self identified themselves as the
autistics and they get very resentful or hurt when they're called a disease or
disorder that in because they say,
well,
we're not an epidemic where we're a person and they,
it's part of this whole neurodiversity movement,
which is quite an interesting neurodiversity movement,
right?
They say their neurodiverse that they,
you know,
maybe think differently from others and they respond differently than others,
but they're not quote abnormal.
And I think they have a good argument.
Hmm.
Um,
I heard a crazy argument once with someone that was,
so,
the point is that it's,
you know,
the,
the impairment like Rachel,
my daughter,
it's not so much for autism that,
uh,
torture,
you know,
ability to have partners or to have a meaningful career.
It's the fact that she has profound in hurricanes,
profound intellectual disability that goes along with it.
Um,
I forgot what I was going to say.
So when,
when they did say that people have,
there's a spectrum,
right?
And some people who are autistic have an incredible abilities.
That's right.
They have incredible mathematical abilities,
musical abilities,
language abilities.
And then some people do not.
And some people have legitimate issues.
Yeah.
With the Rachel's case,
my daughter,
it's a,
she has a pretty good verbal Iq,
80,
90,
but she has a very low performance Iq in 40.
She can't do simple math.
She can't count money.
Uh,
fortunately,
goodwill industries came to her rescue in our rescue and now she works there two
hours a day sorting clothes and,
and that's been really meaningful for her to get a paycheck.
Great.
Even if it's minimum wage.
Yeah.
Right.
Just to do something to feel right and feel part of the mix.
That's huge.
That's huge for everyone.
Wraps a lute.
Absolutely.
Um,
but so there's no,
uh,
there's,
it's not like you could test positive for syphilis or you can test positive for
the flu.
Right.
Although now,
you know,
as I say,
so that's why I don't like using those,
those terms because it,
it puts people on the autism spectrum as though they have a disease or the
store,
which I don't like to do.
But if it is a disorder,
well,
you know,
now we know there are 99 genes that are linked to autism,
but why is it a bad thing to say that you have a disorder if it's just a
disorder?
When people have disorders,
what's the fact?
Well,
you know,
a lot of the individuals in that,
at that self identify themselves as the autistics don't like to think of
themselves as a disorder.
They like to think of the cells is different,
different,
but not necessarily as a disorder.
Right.
But that doesn't help us when we're trying to discuss it.
Does it?
Yeah,
it gets very,
it's,
it's hard.
It gets hard to talk about it.
Well,
it also,
they're,
they're trying to stop you from talking about it in a certain fashion,
which is actually accurate.
Right.
When they have an issue,
there is an issue to say there's no issue.
It's kind of,
it's,
I mean,
there's a reason why so many people are so concerned about autism and vaccines
and just autism in general,
whether it's environmental pollution factor as well that they like to do is they
like to make the distinction between autism,
that nerve,
a diversity thing,
and actually having intellectual disabilities that go along with it.
Okay.
And maybe it's a bit of semantics also,
but they feel strongly about right now if we don't know what causes autism that
we do,
we do well.
We're getting there very closely.
So we've now,
there is a very important paper produced,
uh,
written by group at the broad institute at Harvard,
Mit,
which is one of the premiere genetics genomics organizations in the country.
And they've now identified 99 genes.
It's a,
it's a huge team of scientists,
not only at the brode,
including piece scientists at Baylor College of Medicine,
99 genes involved in autism,
all involved in early fetal development,
early brain development in the first and second trimester of pregnancy.
So now we're starting to really get our arms around what autism is.
And that's one of the things I talk about in the book.
I mean we,
we have learned so much in the last couple of years about autism,
how it begins early fetal development well before kids ever receive vaccines.
And that's one of the reasons I say vaccines did not cause Rachel's autism
vaccines don't cause autism because autism is already underway in early or early
brain development.
Is it possible that some people have this tendency towards autism and it's
exacerbated by vaccines?
I don't think so.
Um,
I think what happens is the sequence of events happens,
uh,
during pregnancy,
but the full clinical expression of autism often doesn't happen until 18 or 19
months of age.
Like Rachel for instance,
wasn't actually diagnosed until 19 months of age.
And there's some fabulous studies now showing that that clinical expression of
autism actually coincides with a big increase in the icts,
in the volume of the brain.
You can actually show on cereal magnet magnetic resonance imaging,
serial Mri,
how the brain starts to,
the brain volume starts to increase.
And that's very important because parents will often remember,
oh my kid got vaccinated are on 18 months of age or 15 months of age and want to
link the two.
But now you can go back to six months of age and this is studies done at the
University of North Carolina Chapel Hill showing so that you can do an Mri at
six months of age and they can predict now with they say with 90% accuracy which
of the kids will go on to develop autism and then you can take it.
What are they seeing?
What?
What are they saying?
They can see I have,
you have to go,
we can go into detail in the paper,
but they can see certain things on signatures on Mri that tells them that this
kid is going to go on to develop.
So in fact there is a way to test positive for autism.
Then with this serial Mris,
that's what they think.
Right?
And now we have the 99 genes so we can even take it back further by doing what's
called whole exome sequencing,
sequencing,
all the DNA,
all the express DNA of an individual.
And in Rachel's case we did that and we actually found a mutation in a gene
controlling a neuronal connections,
which makes a lot of sense if you think about what autism of course.
So,
so there is a way to,
to show whether children will be more likely to develop autism and there's
either,
there is a way to,
to look at their brain through Fmrp at a very early age and,
and also do the Elsa do genetic sequence.
So it's not simply a matter of how they perform on cognitive tests.
That's right.
We're getting much better at getting our arms around the diagnosis.
Why do you think there's so many people that have these anecdotal stories of
their child getting vaccinated?
Especially large doses of vaccines when they hit them with like 10 in a row and
then all of a sudden or meters,
measles,
mumps and rebellions,
the one that gets repeated over and over again.
That's the one that made my child have autism.
I've heard that so many times,
and I've heard it from friends from friends that have children that have autism,
they had a child,
their child got the measles,
mumps,
rubella shot,
and then immediately there was a very distinct change in the child's behavior.
Well,
no question.
When you get the measles,
mumps,
rubella vaccine,
many times kids cry and things like that.
And then autism will then begin sometime between the first and second year of
life.
So it's logical to want to connect the two.
But now we know it's not even plausible because we know that if you go back to
that an MRI at six months of age or go back prenatally,
we can even determine which kids are going to go on to develop autism.
So even though,
and that complementing it complementing it are massive epidemiologic studies
done on over 1 million kids that in fact a new paper was just released this week
showing that kids who get the Mrr get the MMR vaccine are no more likely to get
autism than kids who don't,
who don't get the MMR vaccine.
And the converse is also true.
Kids on the autism spectrum are no more of likely to have gotten the MMR vaccine
and kids not on the autism spectrum.
Okay.
So,
so it's the combination of that,
those big studies of over 1 million kids together with knowing what autism is,
that completely rules out the possibility.
Right.
So these genes,
excuse me,
the,
and the issue with these genes and then the ability to scan the brain with the
serial Mri and the,
so you can tell which children have the propensity.
Is it possible that children have all these issues and then do not get autism or
do 100% of those children with those issues get autism?
That's a good question.
Uh,
I don't know.
I'm a vaccine scientists.
I'm,
you know,
the,
they're not about the rate.
Well,
well,
I'm a biologist on the vaccine scientists who,
who's really tried to do a deep dive and autism doing research on the book
versus Human Development.
Right,
right,
right.
Okay.
So,
um,
so what you're saying though is that if a child does not have these mutations
and does not have these issues that are present and during serial Mri that they
will not go on to develop autism.
Is that true?
As far as we can tell as far as we can tell.
So children without those issues who get vaccinated have have no problems,
which most children have no problems.
Right?
Yeah.
I mean the,
you know,
we've learned a lot about the risk of vaccines and the numbers are
extraordinary.
I mean,
the risk of a severe adverse event happening after getting a vaccine is roughly
on the order of one in a million between,
between one in 1,000,001 in 10 billion.
Um,
so,
and I found an Internet report wants,
is it the light likelihood of getting struck by lightening is one in 700,000.
So it's,
you know,
the likelihood of having a severe event after a vaccine is your best odds are
better,
uh,
of getting struck by lightning than,
and when you say severe event,
what do you mean by severe event though?
Oh,
well,
which is actually a table that's put out by the national vaccine,
uh,
compensation act.
Um,
that includes,
um,
uh,
shoulder injury,
that's one,
uh,
encephalitis and say shoulder injury.
Yeah,
that's actually on from the actual injection point put,
getting,
injecting it in the wrong place.
Oh,
so it goes into the joint or something like that?
Yeah.
Is that common?
No.
So there,
there have been issues where children have adverse effects and reactions to
vaccines.
What do you attribute those to?
But when you know,
one in a million,
I think,
you know,
in some cases,
biological variability,
I think in some cases inadvertently,
if it's a live virus vaccine,
like the measles,
mumps,
rubella vaccine,
and you have an underlying immune deficiency that wasn't picked up before,
then that virus can replicate better,
but very rare things like that.
Right.
So as far as,
you know,
children who are healthy,
who get a vaccine,
it's,
it's not biologically possible for them to develop these traits,
these mutations in the genes and these issues that you see present as best we
can tell.
Right now that seems to be the case,
right?
As best you could tell right now,
it's a great thing to say I,
but for people that are like,
hmm.
On the outside,
like what does that mean?
I'm not a doctor,
I'm not smart enough to understand what doctor Hotez is saying right here.
What is he saying best as we can tell?
How much can we tell?
So here's what we,
we can tell.
Okay.
No,
um,
studies of 1 million children that there's no link between vaccines and autism.
That's number one.
And,
and so let me Parse,
how did they,
let me,
let me Parse this out in two bits.
So there's,
there's the studies on a 1 million children showing that vaccines do not cause
autism.
That's part one.
The second is the epidemic that I'll do and then I'll do a deeper dive on each
of them.
The second part shows not only is their massive evidence that there's no link
between vaccines and autism,
there's no,
because we know so much about autism,
how it begins in pregnancy.
Okay.
So let's go back to the first part.
The first part is studies in over 1 million children.
One of the things that the anti vaccine lobby does is they played this game of
what I want,
if not really a game,
but what they call,
what they do is play this kind of a thing of vaccine whack-a-mole.
Because at first they alleged it was the MMR vaccine and that came out out of
the study that was published in the Lancet in 1998 then another group came along
and said,
no,
we didn't mean the MMR vaccine.
We meant the thigh.
Marisol preservative that used to be in vaccine and the scientific community not
only debunked,
the MMR linked,
they debunked the thigh,
Marisol Ling.
Then the anti vaccine lobby came along and said,
no,
we didn't mean that.
We're spacing vaccines too close together.
Then they changed it to get around again a saying,
now it's the alum or aluminum in vaccines.
So,
and then each time the scientific community responds with massive epidemiologic
studies showing there's absolutely none of those things that are true.
And do you think that it's just when you look at,
say if there's one in a million that has an issue with this and there's,
and it's not autism by the way.
So whatever those issues are that they hear these stories and these stories do
accumulate because there's 300 plus million people in this country and over 10,
20 years of one in a million,
you develop a significant history of cases where children did have issues with
vaccines.
So these people hear about these stories and people are terrified.
Obviously you're,
I have children,
you become very over protective of your children.
You worry a lot.
And then you also don't know,
like,
why do they get so many shots all in a row like that?
Why does the baby get 10 shots in a day?
That seems crazy.
Well,
they don't get 10 shots in a day.
Most of them,
most of the vaccines are now combined.
So for instance,
in one vaccine we can vaccinate against Diptheria Pertussis,
tetanus,
polio,
uh,
haemophilus influenza type B,
which is a terrible cause of meningitis.
And in some cases not even hepatitis.
So one shot is protected for all these combined,
and there's all sorts of studies showing that it's safe to combine them.
And that's fantastic.
Now you can vaccinate with one shot against six diseases.
So,
and these are life threatening disease,
right?
So the only concern is the child's immune system when they're bombarded with
this one.
So a lot of times it causes them as it'd be tired or they gets sick.
Like the apprentice Demian system is not bombarded.
I think that's another kind of a misnomer that the,
or a misunderstanding that's put out by the anti vaccine lobby.
Remember the child's gut,
the intestines and the respiratory tree is,
is this or Oregon's of antigen presentation.
A baby on average has exposed to hundreds of new antigens every day.
So the idea that you're going to quote overwhelm the immune system with a
vaccine against six diseases just doesn't make any sense.
Again,
this is all phony baloney stuff put out by the anti vaccine lobby.